Very different,
very different,
um,
you know,
I mean,
when you shoot with models,
they're professionals and they're paid
to be there.
Um,
and so they,
they typically are trained to take
direction and they're a natural
extroverts.
When you deal with celebrities,
you tend to deal a lot more with a,
with a tendency to be introverted says
at least in front of the,
uh,
the still camera.
And then typically celebrities are not
all that comfortable being photographed
because in reality they're out of
control,
uh,
that the level of their performance is a
very,
very different from that which they
express on a,
onto the motion picture experience.
So they,
you know,
they don't control when the shutter a is
being depressed and what,
uh,
what image comes out of it.
So they tend to be a little,
I'm self conscious of that experience.
And the,
uh,
the role of a portrait photography is to
really be able to,
um,
to either exploit that vulnerability or
to,
um,
or to release it somehow and to get
something out of them.
It's,
um,
it's,
uh,
it can be a tricky experience and it's
always an adventure,
very,
very unique to
experience,
memorable,
all of the experiences,
you know,
I mean,
there are subjects that people,
uh,
who I've photographed multiple times and
have had a,
a great experience.
Shootings.
So,
and with that comes to mind.
Sandra bullock who have shot multiple
times and uh,
uh,
Kate Bosworth,
um,
and Orlando Bloom of course.
And um,
but then,
you know,
I've had similar experiences where the
Philip Seymour Hoffman,
which sort of stands as a,
you know,
one of my favorite portrait.
It's very stoic and very,
uh,
so,
but portrait.
But,
uh,
but it somehow feels like with some
people you really get a photograph and
feel that,
you know,
perhaps with some,
like people might look at it a 20,
30,
50 years from now.